CPAC, the Conservative Political Action
Conference is this weekend, it is going to be
a an amalgam of a disgusting cast of characters,
culminating on Sunday with a speech. Yes.
From former President Donald Trump, his first
on camera speech since leaving the White House
more than a month ago. And we are going to
be covering that live on Sunday. But CPAC is
running into a little bit of a problem. CPAC, it
turns out, invited a speaker who goes by the name
Young Pharaoh. And unfortunately, Young Pharaoh
has said horribly anti-Semitic things, including
completely brained, wacky cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
conspiracy theories. And Pharaoh Young Pharaoh
has now been pulled as a speaker. The Daily Beast
reports that young pharaoh once tweeted out,
there is no historical or scientific evidence
proving the existence of Jews or Judaism. It's
all a complete lie made up for political
gain. He also attacked fellow right wing
commentator Ben Shapiro for his Judaism, according
to Media Matters. He also has conspiracies
about pizza gate, the coronavirus vaccine and
a whole bunch of other things, as reported
by Eric Hanna Noki. He, a young pharaoh in the
past year, claimed that Judaism in itself is a,
quote, complete lie, that the Jewish people
are thieving, and that all of the censorship
and pedophilia, mind you, on social media is
being done by Israeli Jews. Specifically, he has
now been pulled. Now, one of the funniest aspects
of this, and it's funny in a way that's tragic,
is that CPAC put out a statement saying, quote,
We have just learned that someone we invited to
CPAC has expressed reprehensible views that have
no home with our conference or our organization.
The individual will not be participating in
our conference. The funny thing about that is
it essentially applies to everybody that is
speaking at CPAC up to and including Donald
Trump. I mean, look at look at the wording.
Someone we invited expressed reprehensible views
that Trump is at the absolute top of that list.
So if they were going to go by that standard,
CPAC would have to be canceled. What CPAC
actually means is someone's reprehensible
views went beyond being considered reprehensible
only by the left. And even some people on the
right consider these views reprehensible. So at
this point, we really have no choice but to cancel
the speaking engagement of young
farro. Now, speaking of cancelation,
one of the new prominent memes on the right
around free speech and suppression of speech
is so-called left wing council culture, which
includes, of course, at the micro level. And I'm
doing my best to represent the hypothesis. Left
wing individuals, employers and organizations,
quote, canceling people when they have the, quote,
wrong opinion about things. And it goes up to and
is inclusive of Twitter at large, including its
terms of service, big picture, YouTube, Facebook,
basically anyone who has ever limited the ability
of right wingers to continue publishing weaponized
speech, including that which targets all sorts
of different individuals based on membership in
different protected classes that cancel culture
according to the right. But what's very funny,
or maybe it's not funny, maybe it's just sad
and ironic is that when Fox News canceled Lou
Dobbs because Lou Dobbs was giving a ridiculously
not based, in fact, opinion about the election of
Joe Biden in November, Fox News said he's got
to go and they canceled Lou Dobbs. And yet in
the days following in all of the segments about
council culture on Fox News and Newsmax and on,
they didn't mention Lou Dobbs being canceled.
Now, the right wing Conservative Political Action
Conference has canceled a right wing commentator
for his opinions. That's not part of the council
culture, even though they won't stop talking about
Bill de Blasio this and Twitter that. And Susan
Wojcicki was just that other thing based on what
YouTube, Twitter or others are doing. So. Even
the idea that they care about cancer culture is
laughably untrue. They care only about instances
of repercussions to speech that are politically
advantageous for them. That's all it is.